okay so spider-man now at home build
upon the last 20 years of the sony
spider-verse to bring us a film that
broke the mcu in order to make one of
the biggest events in comic book movie
history seeing andrew garfield and toby
maguire appear on screen together
alongside tom holland was something that
we never thought could happen but marvel
delivered this massive event to make it
the highest grossing film this side of
the pandemic i hadn't felt that hype
since jay-z and naz appeared on stage
together during the i declare war tour
and it's still something that gives me
goosebumps every time i watch it
i know you can feel the magic baby
what i think of the film excel that
though was giving andrew garfield's
peter parker a much deserved redemption
arc when you hear everything that went
on behind the scenes with him it's not
difficult to feel sorry for the actor
and when he played the character he had
several things riding against him the
amazing spider-man released in 2012 just
five years after toby mcguire appeared
as peter parker in spider-man 3. the
amazing spider-man 2 dropped two years
later in 2014 and it would be a mere two
years after that in which he was
replaced by tom holland in a complete
reboot of the character garfield was
actually due to announce the amazing
spider-man 3 at a brazilian comic book
movie event but he called in sick and
then the project was scrapped it was
only after the sony email hack that we
found out amy pascal had been in talks
with kevin feige to reboot the character
in the mcu and garfield's version was
swept into the rug by the studio online
though there was still a massive
community that supported him and just in
the same way that the snyder cut had
several people writing for it garfield
did too thus seeing him back on the big
screen alongside toby and tom was a
major moment that not only righted the
wrongs of the past but it also showed
the growth of the character for the last
decade lots of people have argued who
the best live-action spider-man is and
after seeing them on screen at the same
time i actually think that garfield is
by far the standout in my opinion he
swings circles around the other two and
it's easy to see why he's had such a
massive career outside of this franchise
now not only does the film give
redemption to garfield but it also gives
redemption to his version of peter
parker the amazing spider-man 2 ended
with the love of his life gwen stacy
falling to her death and after he
misused his webs he ended up breaking
her neck it's arguably one of the most
tragic moments in the spider-man movie
ever and though the death of uncle ben
and may are definitely up there this
hits a lot harder because it was caused
somewhat directly by him in the movie we
discovered that this very much broke the
character and then after the death of
gwen he stopped pulling his punches
i lost gwen my um
she was my mj
some point i just
i stopped pulling my punches
this took him down a darker path in
which he became more vengeful and less
forgiving he'd seen firsthand that even
when you try and do good that it can
still lead to loss and had just stopped
giving the villains the benefit of the
doubt like he had in his past now a
theme that's very prevalent in no way
home is the idea of responsibility the
two of the peters that tom's version
meets very much act as a warning in the
wake of ant-may's death not only did
andrew losing gwen make him go down a
darker path but we also see how
something similar happened with toby's
peter he recounts and either uncle ben
died and though he says he managed to
stop the quote-unquote killer it didn't
make him feel better it didn't make it
better
it took me a long time to
learn to get through that darkness
otobi very much saves tom's version from
receiving this same fate in the movie we
watch as the green goblin kills aunt may
and come the final battle peter
completely beats the crap out of him
just in the same way that toby led to
the death of his apparent uncle's killer
tom is about to do the same thing and
finally get revenge on the person that
killed the parental figure in his life
also side note i have to keep saying the
guy who apparently killed uncle ben
because of that stupid sandman retcon
but yeah to me it'll always be this guy
who did it anyway it's a great moment
watching toby stop tom from shoving the
glider into the goblin which is of
course also the way that he died in the
original film it's a very heroic moment
that stops him from becoming vengeful
and filled with anger however the way
that andrew spares him from this path is
far more subtle and he not only saves
tom's soul but also his own after
osborne arrives at the statue of liberty
he hurts goblin bombs and he destroys
the scaffolding holding the structure in
place this causes the entire thing to
collapse and during this destruction mj
falls to her death much in the same way
that gwen did tom's peter leaps out to
grab her but the goblin catches in
mid-air stopping him from saving the
girl that he loves much in the same way
that comics have shown the goblin
killing the person he loves over and
over it seems like history is repeating
itself and this is made even worse by
the fact that osborne also killed may
however andrew's version leaps after her
and he ends up breaking her fall which
in turn saves her life just in the same
way that toby stopped him from traveling
down this dark path due to him killing
his aunt's killer andrew has stopped him
from going down the same one he did
after losing his love he even refers to
mj as his gwen at one point and andrew
carrying this out here also saves
another person from suffering the same
fate that she did rather than using a
web to latch onto her he takes the
impact himself and this shows that he
hasn't made the same mistake it's a
really powerful moment and andrew
completely axes ass off as mj asks him
if he's okay
are you okay
yeah
okay
are you okay
now even though we all watched the
second trailer about 500 times and
figured out that this moment was coming
it still hits home so hard that's the
power of the movie and it showcases that
even when things are telegraphed that
they can still be impactful due to the
performance and also what it means for
the character and actor it's so well
done and it makes you truly see the
impact of exactly what his peter is
going through it saves tom's version
much in the same way that toby stopped
him from killing the goblin and it
spares him from being a spider-man that
refuses to pull his punches the movie is
very much about serving the villains and
throughout it we see as peter does this
even when it's the more difficult choice
however it's also about saving peter as
well and stopping him from becoming
someone that his elder versions wish
they hadn't changed into it's such
amazing storytelling and this scene only
works on a number of levels because of
what it means for the character but also
the actor behind it for fans garfield no
longer feels like he was robbed of
playing the character that he was
obsessed over as a kid but instead we
can leave the film knowing that he
finally got the opportunity to be
clashed shoulder-to-shoulder with the
more favored people that have played him
where we go from here we don't know but
i really hope that the rumblings about
garfield returning are indeed true
whether it's in venom 3 or his own
spin-off movie i think he's someone that
really shines in this film and it shows
that when he's given the right material
he can be the perfect peter parker
watching his two solo films and nowhere
home tied into it really brings his arc
to a close but from this point on there
are several directions that they could
take things we know that he hasn't found
someone after gwen left the hole in his
life and though that may never be filled
i think we all just want to see the guy
happy all in all though that's a story
for another day and after re-watching
the movie knowing what this moment means
to the actor and the character i don't
think that it's anything other than
perfect i'd of course love to hear your
thoughts whether you agree whether you
disagree so make sure you comment below
and let me know we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of an mc box that we chose on the 30th
of january and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check our
video in which we break down andrew
garfield's interview about spiderman
nowy home finally gets to talk about it
and all the things that went into the
movie so definitely go check it out
right after this if not then thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you on the next one take
care peace